[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about the
robot explosion we have Audrey Kay
joining us on the show hello hi it's
such a pleasure to be here again so much
is changing so quickly in robotics it
feels like it's been a lifetime since we
last I know thanks for joining us around
- okay yes and so like you just said so
much has change it was a year ago that
we talked it was around May and you guys
can find the link to that episode below
and since then it's just in like you
said so much has changed we're gonna be
unpacking that in detail for those that
don't know in the hundreds links are
below as well she's the managing
director of Silicon Valley robotics last
eight years doing that she's also the
founder of robot launch global startup
competition we'll be talking about that
a little bit as well we love starting
off with this big history perspective on
civilization here we are at this
interesting AI robotics automation
moment in history what is your current
take on the state of humanity well when
I just look at the state of robotics I'm
really optimistic when I look at the
state of humanity in general I think
today the Doomsday Clock is actually
going back to two minutes ahead of
midnight which is the you know that's
that's pretty severe the sort of summary
of what the state of humanity is but I
do like to be surrounded by people that
take the long view or the deep view of
what our problems are and you know look
at solutions that are going to be really
able to make changes and you know that's
what draws me towards robotics because I
think it's the technology that is going
to be most useful at making positive
change in the world you know I know some
people get scared of it but I really
think it's the answer
to a lot of the grand challenges that
we're facing at the moment whether
that's the aging population the lack the
food supply you know just trying to find
security in our food supply and to
double the amount of food that this
planet is producing in this next
generation so the demand is increasing
all the time
but we have run out of ability to
produce food
our production kind of metric has stayed
really static for the last 30 40 years
and the amount of land that can be
turned into farmland we've really
reached the limits of that and not only
have we reached the limits but we're
reducing that land through both natural
disasters that could be related to
climate or through urbanization the
majority of the world's population is
moving into cities and moving away from
farming how do we fix that how do we
make an abundance of food for everybody
on this planet how do we turn that into
something where people don't have to
fight over access to food or other
natural resources and I think that means
improving productivity across the board
not simply in agriculture but
productivity in every area you know
robotics is a technology allows us to
build much smarter technologies that
ideally can do things like manufacture
in place which is a lot of what the
industry 4.0 ideal is to have local
manufacturing everywhere and really
reduce the amount of moving that things
have to do which consumes a heck of a
lot of energy and and other resources so
robotics may be able to tackle all of
the world's biggest issues is something
that you really see yes major part of
this you've got I said you know aging is
one of them agriculture as another one
of them are insane amount of use of
resources yes energy
and and indeed maintaining all of our
resources on the one hand for example
forestry and mining are the two most
dangerous jobs on the planet so we can
look at it one way which is just can we
make those jobs safer by using
autonomous trucks autonomous digging
machines or robots to help survey
tunnels or go out to oil rig areas so on
the one hand you can look simply at can
we save lives that we're currently in
danger using our resources the way that
we do and then secondly how can they
also assist us in developing new more
effective and more efficient ways of
harvesting energy or converting energy
okay I'm very excited to continue
unpacking this as we keep going so
you've been doing speaking advising
investing just synthesizing the robotics
kind of state of what we have and then
also teaching that to other people now
so what so what's been happening then in
the you know in the history of robotics
yeah well one of the things that first
introduced me to how robotics has
changed in the last 20 30 years was the
way that DARPA instituted Grand
Challenges using robotics and the one
that most people are familiar with is
the autonomous vehicle challenge and
that was all the way back in 2004 2005
and 2007 you know it seems like a really
long time ago but DARPA has a really
good history of looking at something
that is 20 to 30 years out in terms of
the technology our ability our timeline
for achieving that technology and
bringing it at least 10 or 20 years
closer so that it starts to become of
interest commercially and since the
DARPA autonomous vehicle challenge let's
pull up Stanley now so
and that's our that's our next image so
Stanley yes Stanford they were the first
car to win one of the DARPA autonomous
vehicle challenges because I will add in
the very first race nobody won
nobody crossed the finish line nobody
came close but within one year the
technologies have improved so
significantly that there were I think
more than 32 entries and Stanford won
much to the chagrin of Carnegie Mellon
because they had been used to being the
number one contender but at this time
the autonomous driving efforts were
largely within research it was the cars
facility at Stanford and it was Carnegie
Mellon and what happened straight after
that is that Google started acquiring
self-driving technologies out of the
universities and that started people
realizing that this might not be 20
years off that some people were starting
to bet or or even unattainable some
people were starting to bet on this
coming in the next 20 years and since
then we've had a lot of people go public
with predictions that we'll have fully
autonomous vehicles from about 2015
onwards we haven't gotten there yet not
at all but we have had self-driving
vehicles on the 101 in the Bay Area and
now in many many other places since 2011
right now there are more than 50
companies licensed in California to be
testing self-driving vehicles safety
company company license and yes and we
go back to 2005 and look at all of those
sensors and lighters that are up on the
top there those are at least twice as
expensive as the brand-new four-wheel
drive vehicle but they're sitting on so
one of the things that's changed since
then if you think about it 2005 that's
pre smartphone mm-hmm
so since then the smartphone has really
contributed significantly to the
revolution in affordable component
technologies that are also useful for
robots aka self
driving cars so smaller chips better
connectivity and smaller cheaper sensors
so those things together better
computation ubiquitous connectivity and
affordable sensors has really been at
the heart of what in fact Gill Pratt who
ran the DARPA Robotics Challenge at that
time he called it a Cambrian explosion
in robotics and that's why for me I'm
living in the middle of that that
resonates so much because what I can see
is not just a quantitive explosion in
the number of robots robot companies and
the funding of robot companies but
there's also a qualitative change and if
you're not really up on your prehistory
the Cambrian explosion is the biological
period which is just a sliver of our
whole biological time line but within
that period we went from having very
very simple organisms that could move
that came in a few different shapes and
sizes to having representatives of every
single variation of life on this earth
just within that period and what is
theorized that led to that is the
development of vision systems the
development of eyes and as organisms
developed eyes they created so many new
ways of growing and using them it became
a case of were you going to hunt other
organisms down or were you going to
avoid them how did you grow to better
meet the new nations that were emerging
in the ecosystem so we had this
explosion of variety not just of
quantity that happen in the Cambrian
explosion and that is exactly what we're
seeing in robotics an explosion in the
quality the variety of sorts of robots
that are out there and it's happened
because we hit this tipping point in
terms of the building blocks of
technology we can now build robots that
have better
sensing abilities yes and that allows
them to do a lot more there were a
couple things that you said that are
really important there um one of the
things that you said it was that it's
fascinating thinking about how Grand
Challenges contribute to cutting edge
innovation from teams around the world
so the more that we can incentivize
Grand Challenges at the scales of
$1,000,000 in prizes you know like
similar to like what XPrize does and
what you know yeah mewn has been doing
with his prizes that we do think that
that's a major driver for innovation
another one that you mentioned was the
fact that these sensors on top of
Stanley used to cost so much money and
now have dropped in cost by is by
support magnet reorders amazing you can
and the range of senses available is
just continuing to increase and the
range of sensing is now increasing so
this is kind of the next point is that
you know we've we see these curves you
know with Moore's law we see these
curves with with with the Carlson curve
with for genomics for sequencing DNA as
well that that all these curves that are
making it more and more inexpensive to
do the computations that we so desire
are causing this exponential technology
age and then this last thing that you
mentioned I thought was super
interesting was that when you compared
the Cambrian explosion biology to the
robotic explosion we're going through
right now or this exponential technology
explosion you also made it clear that it
was because in biological systems due to
the perception so there was perception
and then a new algorithmic sequences of
these biological
organisms are able to then take and see
is it avoiding prey is it going and
finding new prey is it making new
shelters all that kind of stuff
similar with robots now with perception
the exception with robots with
autonomous vehicles with drone
technology with dexterity with all these
different things is leading us into this
explosion so then now what is then
robotics 1.0 vers 2.0 that is a great
question that I look at this and this is
an example of robotics 1.0 but supremely
sophisticated working on human beings
but highly controlled very very
expensive systems we've had surgical
robots since sr I was developing the say
the torus gripping system which was
commercialized by Intuitive Surgical and
this is the what I call the big end of
robotics we've had in robotics 1.0
pretty much two varieties of robots one
is the factory industrial robot arm and
they're also very expensive they're also
very dangerous and they remain locked
away in cages in factories in no-go
areas you don't have people working with
those robots at all and this one might
even become a collaborative robot arm
because that's quite recent but pretty
much most of what robotics has been for
the last 50 years has been a version of
this robot arm or a very very
million-dollar variant which is the
surgical robot which as said just in
terms of the it's highly controlled very
expensive they have a lot of degrees of
mobility here so they can you know you
spin around on the very bottom you angle
this arm you extend it out what is it
how many degrees of freedom is it look
that one maybe only has three but now
the cut if you count the end but the
cutting edge is what like seven or
something
well I think we've had robotics 1.07
axis mills if you think about it just a
CNC machine subtractive manufacturing
during seven degrees of freedom you can
do highly complex geometries you can
mill metals like titanium you can
construct parts for the aerospace
industry or you can perform surgery
these are great but they like I said
they don't have the ability to work
beyond their own you can't reprogram on
the fly and you can't get in the way of
their work envelope so these are
machines that lack perception these are
machines that are effectively simply
executing code all being teleoperated
directly by the operator these machines
do not think for themselves indeed if
you look at the definition of Robotics
which says a machine that senses thinks
and then acts you would have to say that
almost every robot 1.0 company isn't
really a robot anymore because they
sense and they execute code or execute
joystick commands as it were to take
action they're not making decisions
they're not really being driven by
perception in the loop robotics 2.0
companies look like those robot arms but
they're able to navigate around people
because they'll have different
mechanisms that allow them to sense
people they'll also be able to be mobile
that's the big change self-driving cars
but also mobile robots inside of
supermarkets or delivery carts or
vehicles or mobile robots within
warehouses or on farms or in mines so
this is navigating in its environment
yes
safely around people right so it's using
perception to navigate and that's where
I'd go back to saying even the robot arm
that we were showing before isn't really
a robotics 1.00 arm because it's got a
perception system there yeah at least of
some kind and quite often you'll find
that there is touch sensing capacitive
sensing force sensing or there are
cameras inside of a work envelope so
there are a range of ways that robots
now can sense if somebody's interfering
with work and take the appropriate
action or they can respond so you can
retrain a robot and you can say
pick up this like this and someone
doesn't need to really call in a very
expensive integrator or rewrite code you
can push a button and retrain a robot
system so this is the essence of
robotics 2.0 it is qualitatively
different
the robots are employing perception and
this gives them the ability to navigate
in the real world and while we might not
have fully self-driving cars on the road
yet we now have autonomous robots in our
supermarkets we now have delivery robots
in parts of the world whether it's a
warehouse or a suburb in Arizona so
we're seeing robots coming out of the
factory and out of research into the
real world and we're starting to see the
numbers climb robotics 1.0 industrial
robots there are fewer than 2 million of
them in the world now 2 million might
sound like a lot of figures but back in
2011 2012 Fox cons chief said I'm going
to put 1 million robots into my
factories by the end of 2014 which the
newspapers all it they gobbled that up
but everyone in robotics went there are
only at that point in time one and a
half million industrial robots in the
world where are you going to get you
know how are you going to double the
number of robots in production the
world's capacity for building robot arms
suitable for use in factories is already
max capacity you can increase by X
percentage you are not going to get 1
million robots in a three year time
frame he did not he has kept that vision
alive though and he's increased Foxconn
some robot production and the number of
new producers of robots has increased so
we're now at 2 million industrial robots
we're expanding the range of categories
of what robots are and the number of
companies building robots has quadrupled
and of course within those changes a lot
of those companies have shifted so some
of the European and American companies
that we're building robots have been
acquired by Japan and China
Japan's in number one Japan is the
number one producer of robots in the
world today and China is the number one
consumer of robots in the world today
and those changes have really just come
about in the last couple of years
Europe Germany in particular they have
the highest concentration of robots in
use per capita of society and in
generally general terms the US is around
about fifth place across all of those
statistics
yeah when when you're explaining the
difference between one point on 2.0 I
think it's so so awesome that that
robotic perception and then being able
to then process that stimuli and even if
you need to dynamically make code
deployments or to just you know make it
so that it can relearn on the fly is so
fascinating and then make decisions as
well and and like you were explaining
here now you've got now you have 90 of
instances where the robots like instead
of being in behind enclosed areas where
you can't operate by humans with the
perception systems that we have with the
2.0 era they can engage around humans
and potentially stop if there's a human
coming by all of these robots and this
is what I call robotics 2.0 they're
mobile they're capable of taking the
right sort of avoidance behaviors around
people and to make some sorts of
predictions as to how people are going
to move and clearly within if you look
just within a supermarket aisle you're
going to find many different types of
movement you're going to find a store
associate for example they might spend
quite a lot of time at any one spot in
the store and not move easily they might
have boxes beside them you will find
people that have trolleys and strollers
and moving up and down and you will find
that children will have a very different
movement pattern to adults who are
shopping and you know just to be able to
make a reasonably accurate assumption as
to whether or not somebody is going to
need to intersect with your path
and how to deal with that we've been
working in the field of human robot
interaction for a very long time on
scenarios like this and it's so exciting
to see those scenarios turn into
real-world issues and there are at least
a half dozen companies with large
deployments at major retailers like
Walmart Target Kroger Amazon Alibaba
in fact there's probably more than 12
companies doing just inventory robotics
alone and within the retail umbrella
there are probably five or six different
deployments of robotics technology that
are getting put into trial right now and
that ranges from say robotic shopping
carts to the frictionless checkout yeah
- if we have right here standard
cognitions located right here just yeah
right in this exact same building it's
crazy so and what else is nuts of when
we're looking at this not only like
you're explaining is it mobile I think
what else is nuts is that there's sight
there's - perception systems got
happening simultaneously there's the one
that's actually scanning inventory and
processing that and then uploading that
data for the for the for the retailer to
know where to go and send people to go
stock and suits and robots to go stock
and then to the other perception system
that's crazy is the one where it
actually has to go and make sure that
the humans that are walking up and down
the aisle is the ones that are stalking
the kids that are probably trying to
come and play and touch that robot as
they're avoiding that and then it's
really cool that you said that there's
you know a dozen and I just want to over
the different sort of robotics companies
that are were retail robotic inventory
companies I wanted to make clear like I
saw a post I believe it was Andrew Angus
reposting about how the that there is a
significant amount of jobs you know
inventory management jobs that are
disappearing because of this I also find
it interesting to at least ask the
question well how many hundreds if not
thousands of people are now working as
engineers designers ops people marketers
of these new companies as well so so
what is your what are your thoughts on
the amount of jobs that are
essentially lost but also gained really
use assuming that jobs are being lost
because if this is really premature
firstly because every robot deployment
that I know of tends to need to have a
caretaker you know a robot Wrangler
robots are still really stupid and you
know what we want is them to behave
perfectly around people what we need is
to have someone to go and find it when
it's gotten boxed in in a corner because
someone put out a tray of something and
it can't get out what we need is people
to just look after the robots constantly
so working in robotics has a really big
skill range by fine robotics companies
all the time looking for people just to
help manage deployments to physically
baby sick robots so we're gonna need
robots baby set first off it's not
necessarily a high school job second off
when you look deeply into the actual
task that's being taken these robots are
running constantly how often was
inventory being done in that store
previously and it's more likely to be a
handheld inventory scan on a weekly
basis an empty shelf scan on a daily
basis and then a large stock take once a
year so when you find out how rarely
something is happening you realize this
is the characteristic of a commercially
successful robotics deployment is it's
not taking a job because if a person is
doing that job all the time people are
still really flexible and really good at
the jobs that they do but if it's
something that is really hard for people
to do so we can only fully inventory a
store once a year well we're finding out
that a job like that tends to have very
inaccurate results when compared to a
robot survey of the same inventory more
inventory data points over time which is
exists not just at the time but the
comparison that most of the major
retailers have found between their
annual stock takes and the robots report
the quality of the robot inventory
taking is twice as good as their human
inventory taking and this was the best
inventory taking that they could get
yeah so it's like right now
humans are definitely better at dynamic
management or situations whether that's
you know pinpoint stock reshelving or
customer service or adapting to all of
the different jobs within a supermarket
but robots are really good at doing
those monotonous kind of tasks and in
fact one of the hallmarks of robotics
1.0 has been what people call the 3ds
and that's dull dirty dangerous and I
say it's actually the four DS because
these are the dumb robots the dumb
robots that can't really navigate
successfully robotics 2.0 robots like
these I say it's the four SS mmm they're
smarter they're sensor based they're
capable of social interaction even if
it's mom verbal interaction so they may
be capable with a dialogue but they're
also capable of navigating around people
understanding that this is a shared
space yeah so they have to have social
ability even just a little bit but the
limitation of them where the four DS of
robotics 1.0 means that effectively
they're dumb the limitation for robotics
2.0 is simple single tasks simple robot
smarter sensor based social yes but each
of these robots is doing one thing yeah
they are not taking inventory and
stocking the shelves they are not
providing navigation around the store
they're doing one task and they're
focusing on getting that task right and
a lot of robot companies in the early
days of developing retail robots made
the mistake of trying to put everything
on board the robot to see what was going
to stick so they had the ability to scan
parts the ability to tell you operate
telepresence bring in an associate from
somewhere to ask questions the ability
to provide navigation and guidance you
know everything was being test
stood out it was a very experimental
stage and ultimately a robot that can do
most things 60% well is just not
necessary what we need to keep focusing
on is doing one task out of the whole
range that a human in this store can do
but doing that one task at a really
successful level so what I say it's the
four SS smarter sensor based social
simple really simple yep and then when
you get really good at doing the simple
task and you're with the robotics 2.0
you can combine the simple tasks once
you've gone really really good at those
into potentially a single dexterous
Boston Dynamics style robots everything
around the store although I think you
know it's going to be an interesting
case and we'll see people taking
different directions there might be one
store that chooses to have the robot do
both infantry and shelf stocking but I
think it quite likely that we'll
continue to have a robot doing inventory
and then a completely differently
designed robot doing a shelf stocking
interesting yeah
okay now you're doing a lot more writing
as well right now which is very good and
it's on kind of like the Curt you know
the current state we've been talking
about that a little bit and where it's
going into all of the different
industries and then you were mentioning
you know social robotics which you're
very interested in right now so teach us
about that well my background area was
human robot interaction but also the
socio or the sociology of robotics
which is really understanding what
robots do we end up within society why
do we have those robots how do we
interact with those robots at a broad
level whereas I find human robot
interaction tends to focus on the
psychological and while it's fascinating
I think that how things operate
in the wild and at large is often very
very differently to what we've seen in
small interactions so I'm very
interested in robot interactions in the
wild and its scale so part of my work
has been with Silicon Valley robotics
doing commercialization for emerging
robotics companies and another part is
just looking at what is happening in
terms of where robotics is going our
robots going to be good first are they
going to be bad for us how do we
navigate that and how do we provide
people with the best possible
information about that as well so we
don't really need to know about the
uncanny valley that's something people
love talking about they love talking
about Asimov's laws for robots but I can
tell you right now that you cannot code
ethics or morality into a robot just is
not gonna happen this was interesting
when you were talking about this with me
a little bit ago and I want I wanted to
know more about you know we can't we
were still struggling on the human
ethics and morals level so it's very
difficult to figure out how to how to
possibly do that on a robotic level but
on on a on a governance level and on a
lawmaking level in order to ban you know
killer robots that type of stuff that is
something that we can do well absolutely
and I think part of the realization that
there are things that we can do is about
realizing that it's human society and we
have certain frameworks through which we
control or we express our desire for
what kind of society we want and I think
fear-mongering is not the best way to
help us take the constructive actions
that we do need to take because on the
one hand robots and AI are going to
cause problems definitely but we need
those technologies to solve our Grand
Challenges as as humanity we need to fix
food we need to
clicks health we need to fix the
inequality of wealth distribution we
need to you know conserve our planetary
resources there are so many things that
I do believe new technologies are the
way forward because we can't humanity
has never shown any ability to go
backwards you know push those babies
back in not happening okay and in fact
all societies that have tried to limit
to growth have turned into the worst
possible fascist state so if we're going
to go forward with the technology what
we need to do is have a deep
understanding of where and how those
problems will arise and where and how
the solutions for those problems arise
there are
oh I lose count of the number of groups
that have suddenly been convened to talk
about ethics in robotics and AI from the
World Economic Forum from the Pope who's
just set up a group life Institute yeah
everybody and I'm involved in a number
of them so yes we're concerned but the
group that has had the best broad
solutions
this is arisen from workshops around the
ethics of robotics and AI in the UK from
the EPSRC group engineering we can find
the exact link but on the robot state
site I have my version of this
simplified a little bit so robot assists
or people interested in robotics can
understand it a little more easily and
what I love most about their approach
has been only five guidelines for
example the coelom of principles number
at least 27 and B by Triple E guidelines
on ethical design frameworks for
robotics and AI eats hundreds and
hundreds of pages and I look at the
volume being produced and I think how is
any startup or research lab going to you
know bring in all of that and come up
with ideas about what they aren't going
to do how does any policymaker
understand what they should be pushing
for and what they shouldn't anyway with
the absolute guidelines what I call the
five laws of good robot design we start
right up at the top of Maslow's
hierarchy of needs and it's don't build
killer robots just there are very few
technologies that are single function
most technologies are multi-function but
the nuclear bomb is one example of a
single function technology you pretty
much can't use that for anything else so
there are certain military developments
that would be single function
robot killing machines and there is a
worldwide call to ban those we have
already conventions on acceptable
weaponry whether its nuclear or chemical
and in fact pretty much everyone in the
world has signed on to these conventions
with regards to robots the exceptions
being Russia and the United States so
that is an obviously good guideline
don't build killer robots when their
sole purpose is to kill the next
guideline is really don't build robots
that break the law and you think well
that would seem intuitive surely but
it's not the case there are many
examples of a robot technology that
breaks the law being built and deployed
and then getting into trouble later on
for example deploying telepresence
technologies in Europe where there are
much tighter privacy guidelines here's
one of the issues that's starting to
come out now you're voice-activated
assistance and any robot navigating with
camera technologies is going to be
breaching privacy as we currently
understand it and as our legal
frameworks in certain countries define
it so here's the good news is that some
countries have a very strong interest
and already a structure to look at
privacy and technologies the u.s.
doesn't so you can get away with a lot
of breaches of privacy in this country
without it being against the law but if
you think about that that's kind of good
basic sense guideline to have understand
what the human laws are and then think
about am i building a technology that is
going to be in breach of the law and
then we get down to the middle level
which is like as we get closer and
closer to the individual robot on the
technology stack are you as a company
building a reliable product we have
insurance industries we have product
safety guidelines now it's not foolproof
you know cars are being recalled all the
time through issues with poor product
maybe it's just poor component supply or
an unexpected interaction between
different components but we expect we
have an expectation that if you say your
robot is going to do this that it will
do so and it will do so reliably and it
will do so safely so that's the third
law build good products and then it gets
a little bit more opaque a little bit
more interesting it's the idea that the
robot is going to do what we say it's
going to do how are we communicating
that and who's going to be building the
robots so the key principle here is
don't build deceptive robots and given
that the advertising industry is really
bankrolling a heck of a lot of our
Internet connected technologies today
they're going to be strongly behind most
of our consumer facing robots in the
future now are they going to be clearly
telegraphing who is controlling the
robot who has designed the robot and
what that robots purpose is for actually
this is a really great example to hold
on because the final law for me is its
identification and it comes down to the
individual robot level is there an
identifier in all areas where physical
goods can be dangerous to us which is
airplanes see vehicles land vehicles we
have a licensing and registration
process and those must be displayed but
look at these robots mm-hmm where is
their licensing where is that
information in this one we can see a
brand name but this keeps coming up in
robotics for me and I think it's perhaps
one of the simplest and yet most
significant things that we can do how
are these robots telegraphing to the
world around them who owns them and what
their purpose is and if for example one
of these robots runs over your toddler's
toes what are you going to say
there might very very soon in the future
be four different robots on these Isles
and two of them might be owned by the
store doing inventory and shelf
restocking but two of them might be
owned by other companies
one person is with their disabled friend
or it is a disabled person who is coming
through the shop in their robot powered
wheelchair and another person might have
their robot powered shopping trolley but
it's a third party it's not a standard
shopping trolley and in fact we've seen
quite a few of these you can have your
own follow me robot cart you get it out
of your car trunk and it follows you
around the shops so four different
robots each potentially from diff each
from different companies first data how
do we say the robot that ran over your
child's toes how do we identify the
robot so I think that this is where we
do have to go just as a standard next
and for me
each race five really simple laws is a
way that our policymakers can see the
existing policy structure applying to
the technology
the identifier one is so interesting we
have it for cars and boats and planes
and it's time to get it onto all of the
robotics that are out and about and
those identifiers will help like be said
with communication you call the
telegraphing yeah that's more what we'd
use in the interaction studies but
another recent example is the drones
that shut down the airport in London I
believe some crashed drones were
recovered from the perimeters of the
airport but there was no way to
understand the fighters who owned them
yeah you know and I'm not saying that
bad actors wouldn't avoid that but you
would straightaway know whether or not
someone was a bad actor like have they
taken the license plates off the robot
oh that's an indication that yeah it's
not behaving well so we have frameworks
in society that technologies properly
designed can fit within so that we can
behave that we can produce the best
possible behaviors from robots yes we
can't code that directly into the robot
itself it really the onus is on us
interesting so the difference between
having social fabric frameworks that
would help make robotics successful
versus the inability to be able to
program the morality or ethics into them
can't no no one's worked out how to
program you know morality or ethics into
people successfully you know many people
try but I wouldn't call it an
unmitigated success and if we look at
the limitations of robotics perception
and computation right now both robots
and the disembodied artificial
intelligences are still incredibly
limited they're very far away from an
actual appreciation of place of context
that's just the giant leap forward and I
believe that that's a very long way away
and then is there potentially something
that we've used with humans that has
been maybe a a one could say like a very
successful individual trait or skill
that we've developed that has helped a
lot with morality and ethics like maybe
like meditation has been one that's like
quite quite objectively proven to be
great for a better ethical moral
behavior so is there something like that
for robots that we could potentially say
could be coated in well cool I think
when we have more sophisticated behavior
from robots we can look at those
I think meditations are really
interesting one because what it does is
it removes some of the urgency of action
hmm and I do think that humans get in
trouble a heck of a lot by taking action
on their what you'd call their kind of
systems one thinking not their systems
to thinking on their impulsive ities and
their emotions rather than on a more
considered kind of choice of action you
know if I was rewriting Facebook I would
put a timer on everything you know so
that you can't just immediately publish
something you have to sit with it for a
day before you can share it and then it
allows you to have changed mood and step
back from something although I'm sure
there just be ways that people would
override that but I don't think we
should allow the instant anonymity and
anonymity is the other thing that allows
bad human behavior and we have seen this
with the internet over and over again
and I think this goes back to how people
work face to face we accepted behavior
where you might do something in private
that is not accepted in public but you
would be aware of that and you would
change your behavior because social
acceptance is a really massive motivator
for people so I think the ways that we
can look at coding that into robots
they're so far off appreciating that on
any intern
level but by putting identification on
robots we eliminate the ability of them
to operate anonymously interesting we do
see that quite a bit with anonymous
internet use and some of the propaganda
troll bot farms that we've seen that
with anonymous actors can kind of create
a lot of noise and issues online versus
having identifiers towards an actual
human or towards a license for a robot
in this case could potentially make it
so that everyone has a sort of a data
fusion happening around their social
credit or their social score and that
seems to be one of the ways that we can
prevent malevolence --is do you see that
as as like a robotic social credit as
well of how well a robot is behaving as
well I definitely think you know I'm
looking forward to more creative ways
that we rethink our online behaviors and
then I think that that might be able to
cross to more robotic human interactions
but I think we have to develop a few in
a really experiment with a few better
ways of building our our non
face-to-face communications if you think
about it in reducing the human component
of our communications really
significantly on each improvement
forward and now as you said we've got
communications that are more noise than
signal and most of the noise is very
very negative so I think we need to fix
that first I agree with you you went
right the horrific comment anonymously
few had to look at the person in the
eyes in person that's that's a very
interesting point and then molasse
thought around this is what you know you
gave us a little taste at this earlier
I'm really curious about your thoughts
about it there's so much propaganda
happening in the media about job loss
and I think it's really interesting to
ask you
to go a little deeper into this there's
a tremendous amount of jobs being
created by automation robotics
artificial intelligence so many new jobs
that are still unheard of right for the
youth in augmented reality technologies
all of you excellent job that I see a
robot doing is an area that it has a
huge vacancy it's it's tasks that people
aren't doing otherwise there's very
little commercial incentive the cost of
human labor is incredibly cheap and as
said humans are incredibly good at
things so a lot of the studies that are
all fear and well about robots and jobs
have been quite comprehensively debunked
and a lot of them rest on a very broad
definition of robots that is actually
computerized automation which has had
some significant impacts there are
entire professions that have shifted one
example though for example is ATMs and
people were worried that the rollout of
ATMs was going to reduce the number of
local banks and remove the number of
bank telling positions and it's seen the
opposite it's seen an increase in that
because it's become cheaper to provide
the full services and what you tend to
find is that the mundane surface of just
getting money out is handled by the ATM
but anything that's a little more tricky
is handled by the bank staff and that's
one of the industries that has seen a
growth the other thing is robots it's
taken quite a while to produce the
number of robots that we already have
one of the biggest problems we're facing
in robotics right now is can we scale
the market wants robots but we're having
difficulty producing robots and we're
having difficulty staffing robotics
companies and that is just going to get
worse because
the demand for labor and it ranges from
unskilled to very skilled is so
significant over history human
unemployment rate has remained
remarkably stagnant and our labor
statistics go back through at least one
technological rig well they go back
through three technological revolutions
including the Agricultural Revolution
where we went from sixty percent of the
population employed on farms to less
than 2% mm-hmm okay that is a huge shift
in a job but unemployment overall
remains steady so we shift jobs we don't
seem to be really cognizant of the idea
that we could perhaps eliminate this
type coupling between employment and
earnings and start really being creative
and saying well maybe all humans should
have earnings to put back into the
economy and make it a really yeah so
there's one whole debate there
yes shifting the shift of jobs is very
interesting I want to I know you've
already answered some of our ending
questions on simulation I just want to
see if maybe you've had any thoughts on
like the updates on if you think we're
in a simulation I struggle with the idea
like I've looked at the theories but I
still struggle with the idea that a
sufficiently advanced simulation would
be necessary or desirable
you know it's like we're building so
much bad in the simulation to me it kind
of defeats the purpose but you know I
just focus more on what we're actually
doing day to day and seeing what I can
do to you know make the world a better
place and this is one of the other areas
with robotics that we often forget about
there's a strong
movement towards looking at the robots
that augment humans rather than the
robots that replace humans and steal
jobs hybrids yeah yeah whereas I think
you know if we you looked at that NASA
image we tend to think of the robot as
being important Mirotic Ronnie as we can
yeah yeah yeah and there you look at as
a mirror yeah that that's a very
interesting that's you know absolutely
down to where I am drop a morphic bias
you know when we think about robot we
think about it as a reflection of human
and as of having all of those same
capabilities and issues and it's that
kind of thinking that gets us into
trouble so robots are not reflections of
human except insofar as we can put the
surface dressing on I think it's
actually they're a fascinating mirror
back at us where we realize exactly what
it is we think humans are about and
where we can reflect on what differences
having a different perception system can
make you know how robots think and
perceive is so incredibly different what
I love about this image is because I
always wanted to be an astronaut and
discover alien life and I think this to
me is discovering alien life right here
on earth
and it's discovering AI yeah yeah yeah
it is that's it's a good way to put it
and then this is potentially us passing
the torch to the non-biological
intelligence but also we would like to
embed consciousness in the
non-biological intelligence so there can
be the feeling of being in in the cosmos
exploring and playing and experiencing
yes yes well I think if we look at the
studies about the animals yes okay we
might start to see that consciousness is
not simply a human property
yes correct yeah the very pants I kissed
the consciousness infinite consciousness
is all that is absolutely last last
thought is let's see if you've updated
what do you thinks the most beautiful
thing in the world the view of Earth
from space especially if it means that
we're going to space too
I guess just broadened the base for
Humanity I'm so excited for whatever's
coming in a robotics 3.0 I'm very I can
talk about robotics 3.9 next time yes
we've got some things to say yes yes
let's see what is the next four for X's
you have now let's see what your next
array or acronym becomes because holy
cow the perception systems are getting
better this has been such a cool update
on the robot explosion and under your
work is so important and interesting and
we hope you we wish you the absolute
best and we wish civilization the best
what's yes yeah how to integrated
hybridize with this thanks for coming
along again thank you thank you yes huge
thank you to Ron Vargas our producer
director we love you very much thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we'd love
to hear your thoughts in the comments
below let us know what your thoughts are
on the current state of the robotic
industries also do check out Andres
links below go and support Andre support
us at simulation as well all our links
are below support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in go and
have more conversations with people
around you about robotics and automation
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much and we will see you soon peace
[Music]
[Music]